thank you
your call has been forwarded okay
kimberly doesn't answer dang man i've
been good to prank my mom man that would
have been good and that's a good prank
too let's try it one more time i want to
prank my manager
um
yeah we could say
we looked at his posts
you should call and say preacher isn't
doing the show anymore in vegas
like that you should call as and be like
hey preacher wanted me to call you let
you know he's replacing you
as management
yeah you should replace him
okay
or we can also send me his his or her is
it he or her who is it it's it
it's a he
oh it's uh
yeah yeah i know who they are
the management company
um
all right um
well except from freeman
is hosting the uh
um
anti-vaccine porn
anti-vaccine porn yeah um
okay give me his give me his number okay
i just sent you his number okay his name
is zach waxenberg okay
wow
yeah a jewish manager who's ever heard
of that he's actually black
yeah but so was sammy davis jr you're
right very true okay
all right
hello
hi this is zach hi i'm looking for zach
yeah my sister yeah my name is neil
framos and i'm with um hr at mgm
properties
um do you represent preacher lawson
yeah yeah so he's going to be doing the
agt show
um
at the luxor
okay so we do uh obviously we've done
and background checks we didn't know who
to talk to i'm calling you this is the
first call we have found some of his
posts um inappropriate
for our
liking um uh in the last week he's had
an anti-vaxx post
and on april
fools he um
put up we notice he has an only fans
account
um
not not an actual one no we we checked
into it he has actually subscribed and
he does have an actual only fans account
yeah i mean there's nothing like
graphic uh that's been posted in that
no but the point is that is a
you know for all intents and purposes it
is a porn site and we are a family
property and so he has an only fans
account and also an
anti-vaxx post we don't like to
have any of our employees be
political
or
in any way you know offensive to our
customer
base
totally got it um
i'm uh i'm happy to talk to him i'm sure
won't be a problem to take anything down
um well we're thinking about we're
calling we were just got off the line
with uh people at fremantle
sharon de boningi
and um she said that it is possible to
replace the host so sharon defonity is
the one that uh is suggesting that but i
said i need to talk to his
representation directly
we can get this all
taken care of what was sharon's last
name
sorry can you spell that i i really i
don't know how to spell it okay can you
just repeat it one more time yeah
sharing the boneless please
does it start with a d or a b
i'm sorry
does it start with a d or a b
well i i don't know i don't know how to
spell it the money
[Music]
works for fremantle she is a
contracted by fremantle she does not
work directly for fremantle
when i was speaking to mr money um for
and we were on the phone for a good half
hour um she tried to explain to me how
you know it was done in the name of
humor but mr bernard said even in humor
it is something that is taken seriously
by our customer base
so what is the next step are you going
to call a preacher
i mean
yeah like i said i'm happy to call i'm
sure you take anything that you want
taken down
um
well the point is that i don't think
we're going to go ahead with the
contract uh i would but uh mr bundling
said that uh it's not something that
she's interested in
okay i need to speak to him
okay you call him and you tell him i
think he's aware of uh i i think that
she might have reached out to him
i need to get preacher's larger team
involved
he's a larger team
what team is what team am i speaking to
is this the the small team because i'd
like to speak to preachers larger team
excuse me sir i'm one of preacher's
managers he has two managers he has an
agent there's a few people in here
you're not going to impress me with the
larger team sir what i'm saying is and
i'm speaking on behalf of myself mgm and
tomorrow
i'm i'm aware i'm just saying i'm not
impressing anyone there's just more
people that are involved in this okay
well the one person that says yay or nay
for us is miss dominion
so it's up to what the my name says goes
if the button says yes it's yes if the
opinion says no it's no and that's where
we draw the line
all right can can you hang on one second
yes do you want me to get the money on
the phone
yeah i'm gonna get oh the larger team
we're getting the larger team together
all right i'm going to i'm going to try
can can you just hang on one second no
no
what what what why is where's the
hostile why is like their hostility
there is no hostile it didn't come from
me it came from sharon to punishing
and she was being hostile we're just
trying to comply it is a customer-based
service and that's what we're doing
you're telling me that the team i called
is too small and this is a job for the
larger team i can't deal with a larger
team i'm dealing one on one with you
sharon de bonner he dealt with me and
only me and didn't ask for a larger team
that's where i'm drawing the line you
know what
stop screaming this is not worth it
sir i'm not screaming at all then
there's no reason to be this upset
please keep your voice down and let's
deal on like human beings here yeah no
absurd absolutely please stop screaming
there is no reason to get oh this is
you're taking this overboard i will call
you back when you calm down i'm not i
will tell you you're back when you calm
down i'm not getting me at all i don't
know what i will not take this kind of
behavior
i hung up oh my god you want to call
your manager or do you want to deal with
it
do you want to call the larger team
oh my god
uh the last name let's see how long he's
going to call it he's going to be
calling everyone else should i should
probably call him now before he calls
the larger team yeah yeah you're awesome
preacher plug his phone in no
yeah well i can i can just call back the
same just call him just you call him and
you can talk i'd be like man that was
howie no well don't don't let it go let
him explain to you what he heard oh okay
cool okay say did you get a call
see i want to see how he explains it
[Music]
hello
hello
hello hey hello this is zach
yeah
yeah this is uh
this is preacher
god man how you doing
good did you get a call
yeah
okay
all right uh
trying to figure it out uh did somebody
contact you
yeah
some um
i think it was some guy he got a call
from sharon the money and
uh i guess he was saying he's gonna call
my team or something like that
yeah he reached out kind of just like
freaking out so i'm trying and then he
hung up so i'm trying to get into
what's going on yeah i mean what's going
on he didn't like give me all the detail
he said he was gonna speak to you he was
like upset with uh i guess some post
he was saying that they were upset with
like the uh the anti-vaxx post and the
fact that you have a only fans page but
i told them that it was but i don't have
any like photos i don't have any photos
or videos or
i i know let me let me get into all this
and uh i'll
i'll i'll call you back shortly can i
can i talk to you for a second
can i talk to you for a second
how are you
zach
yeah this is howie mandel
[Laughter]
amazing
oh my god
now i listen
he's not laughing
i know that was great that would be
great i i i couldn't tell i was kind of
trying to figure that out but sir calm
down
you're on you're on my podcast
oh amazing i was gonna say am i uh am i
gonna do another show
no no no
that's
can i be honest with you that was a
prank sharon he never called me
yeah
he doesn't even know my name oh my god
it's not anybody i've ever met
that is well done thank you there's no
reason to scream at a zack please oh my
god
[ __ ] like that what's the restaurant i'm
with the same management company yeah
yeah i know zach i've known zach for
years but he didn't recognize my voice
oh that you threw it really well
you started off with a different voice
and transitioned back to regular house
well that's the money effect
[Music]